cbd gets you high cbd
doesn't make us feel high in fact it can
reduce the effects
of feeling intoxicated cbd
is a scam it's been used as a marketing
tool
so we really have to be able to weed it
out
no pun intended my name is dr shonda
macias
i am the ceo of alera holistic
healthcare i've been working in the
cannabis industry
since 2011 and i'm dr june chen
i've been an integrative cannabis
physician for over 15 years i treat both
children and adults
and today we will be debunking myths
about cbd
cbd gets you high a lot of people
think that cbd gets you high cbd
doesn't make us feel high but it
definitely makes us
feel less anxious and more relaxed so
when people say they use it to fall
asleep i can understand why we feel that
way
cbd can be extracted from the cannabis
plant but it doesn't have the same
ability to create a high or a state of
euphoria
like marijuana or thc in fact it can
reduce the effects
of feeling intoxicated cbd works the
same
for everyone cbd does not work the same
for everyone
everybody has a different system
physiologically when we think
about patients using cbd and considering
things of what's the right dosage
you have to really consider how heavy
you are
your tolerance levels have you ever used
it before
if you haven't used it how long your
cell receptors will
react to the presence of cbd these are
all the things we have to take into
account
and if you think about prescription
medications or even supplements that's
not the same reaction for everyone
either
so cbd is going to be very very
different for each individual
depending on our metabolism our body's
own enzymes
some patients will find that it works
right away some patients will find that
it takes a few hours
i think that when people use cbd over
the counter they get a little confused
and their confusion might be because
the product might be full spectrum the
product might be at isolate or even
broad spectrum
and you'll have some patients that are
very very sensitive
about introducing their bodies to thc
period because
during accumulated use of thc you could
have a
positive drug test from an
over-the-counter product you always when
taking
any new supplement or cannabinoid
medicine you have to be careful
and it's nice to be able to talk to your
doctor or your pharmacist or even the
dispensary retail workers to see if
there is any possible interaction
cbd doesn't have side effects
so cbd does have side effects for some
patients
it doesn't intoxicate you but it can be
really relaxing and almost produce an
uplifting effect
a small amount of patients will find
that cbd makes them very sleepy cbd does
improve your rem sleep patients that
take cbd
find that if they get a much more
restorative night's sleep
because thc can disrupt rem sleep so
patients will take thc to fall asleep
faster but if they concentrate on more
cbd dominant doses they might find much
more restorative sleep
sometimes patients will find that when
they're taking cbd they do have
stomach upset you know that might change
their bowels a little bit but it's
usually due to the carrier oil
that accompanies the cbd cbd and
marijuana
are the same thing cbd and marijuana are
not the same thing
cbd also called cannabidiol and thc
tetrahydrocannabidiol are the most
common cannabinoids found in the
cannabis plant
a thc and cbd are both in marijuana
and hemp marijuana contains much more
thc while hemp has a lot of
cbd the main difference is i think
preventative care
versus active treatment using cannabis
and if i have a patient that
is facing more pain not preventative
care
then definitely thc helps with that more
than a cbd
absolutely cbd provides that
foundational
anti-inflammatory component so you're
getting to the root cause of the problem
especially with chronic pain
and thc is also very valuable because it
can help with acute muscle spasms acute
pain
nausea appetite increase so i think that
the thc and the cbd work synergistically
together
and we can't stress that enough cbd is
illegal
so i need to debunk the myth that cbd is
illegal in
2018 the farm bill passed the usage
of hemp where we extract cbd from
so the isolate and other cannabinoids
extract leaks strictly from the hemp
plant
is perfectly legal today so what's
interesting
about legal cbd is that the percentage
of thc present has to be lower than
0.3 to remain legal and to be sold
over the counter all in all hemp and cbd
oil are considered
federally legal in all 50 states all cbd
products are safe i have to debunk that
myth
because we know that cbd products are
allowable
on the regulated market but they're also
available on the illicit market
which are not products that are required
to have
testing and the identification of their
different ingredients
the problem with cbd is that it's not
fda regulated so really anyone can come
out with a product
and put it on the internet to sell cbd
eye drops have not been tested
cbd aerosolized nebulizers have not been
tested
or the nasal spray have not been tested
so it really is on the onus of the
consumer and the patient to make sure
that it is effective and reliable and
third party tested it's as simple as
checking the label looking for what's
called a coa
certificate of analysis because that coa
will tell you the quality of the cbd
source
it will list all of the information that
is key i'm telling you
potency is there any bacteria or fungus
or are there any solvents or heavy
metals or pesticides that have been
tested on the label
you want to make sure that that lab has
been accredited so it's tested by an
accredited lab
so unfortunately there's a lot of
homework that consumers and patients
have to do
make sure that that cbd product is as
good as what it says does
when you purchase cbd make sure you
purchase it from a credible resource
like if you're in a pharmacy
and they have it on their shelves
usually there is some type of
vetting of the product versus a gas
station you know
there might be a compromise in the
quality of the product all cbd
is the same i debunk that myth all
cbd is not the same the molecular
structure of cbd is the same but
quality control could definitely be
different
and it also depends on the formulation
some of my patients that use cbd
for anxiety or for panic attacks and
sometimes
before that panic attack comes on before
you start spiraling you need something
to work within 30 seconds and that's
when you would use an inhaled version of
cbd
such as the vape cartridge or a flower
and some of my patients have
terrible pain spasm and inflammation and
they need something that will work
throughout the day
they can't leave work or take a break to
go outside and use something that's
inhaled so they need something that's
long lasting and that's when they would
use a capsule or a tincture
cbd fixes everything cbd is not
a miracle pill it's not the silver
bullet is not a miracle elixir to
all things it cannot cure everything
that moves
i have to agree completely cbd has
its known benefits and we embrace those
but
if i lose my car key cbd is not going to
find it for me
when you think about cbd you definitely
need to keep it within its realm
and i think that it's definitely can
lead the pathway to
integrative health benefits but i think
common sense needs to come into play
when we use cbd
i don't think cbd in cannabis cures
parkinson's
but for my parkinson's patients it
decreases the tremors
it decreases the muscle spasm and pain
it increases appetite and gives my
parkinson's patients better quality of
life so
i think it's a piece of the puzzle cbd
is
addictive cbd is not addictive but i can
see
why social media says that cbd is
addictive
because cbd is derived from the cannabis
plant and many of people
associated with marijuana and assumes
that there's a potential for
addiction on the contrary the world's
health organization
concluded that cbd is non-addictive with
no withdrawal symptoms
and i can say that as a clinician
patients that i treat that take cbd
are not dependent on cbd matter of fact
i've seen patients that have been
battling addiction has actually used cbd
to help them in their recovery yes
because
cbd and thc can help offset some of
those withdrawal symptoms and it can
decrease pain
decreases that inflammation that nausea
feeling perhaps when you're weaning off
medication
so i often use cbd in cannabis to help
patients wean off opiates benzos and
even sleep aids
cbd cures cancer i always debunk that
myth
but cannabis medicine can help you get
through chemotherapy and radiation that
much better and if it helps you with
your mood
if it helps you sleep better if it
decreases some of your pain and
inflammation and revs up your appetite
or maybe it gives you a little bit of
energy during the day so you can take a
walk
all of these things will help your body
fight the cancer
that much better there's so many
wonderful benefits
of cannabis and specifically cbd
in helping the symptoms of cancer but we
can't say with 100
surety it reduces the densities in
different tumor sizes
without that research element being
conducted properly
so to say directly cannabis cures cancer
is a myth but
cannabis can help you fight the cancer
cbd is a scam i have to debunk this
myth cbd does have its inherent
anti-inflammatory benefits it has pain
relief benefits especially for
preventive care
insomnia and anxiety patients use it for
a lot of these reasons
and it has helped and changed thousands
of lives
i can see why social media would label
cbd
as a scam because over the past couple
of years cbd has been everywhere and
it's been touted as this
miracle elixir if you look at epidiolex
which is an
fda approved plant-derived cbd medicine
for seizures but then you look at the
beverage industry
like budweiser developing beer
or your neighborhood cafe you can add a
shot of cbd
to your morning latte and then you look
at the beauty industry
cbd lipstick or sephora has cbd mascara
for thicker
longer lashes there are some cbd creams
and balms and lotions that work well
but you have to look at if they have an
other added ingredient maybe it's the
menthol that's in the product or the
arnica that's supplementing it and
creating a decreased
sense of inflammation and relief for
your muscles and ligaments
it's been used as a marketing tool so we
really have to be able
to weed it out no pun intended
cbd won't affect other medications
that is not true cbd
may interact with certain medications
and certain natural supplements and if
you take it
in extremely large doses it can actually
elevate your
liver enzymes so seizure medications
if you're on blood thinners certain
patients will find
that if they take cannabis elderly
patients that there could be a fall
precaution maybe they're taking too much
thc
and they're a little bit dizzy or groggy
and i think that's why it's so
important that patients work where
physicians
specifically those that are educated in
the endocannabinoid system
so that they can help them on that path
to wellness
when patients come to see me asking
about cbd or cannabis for their health
and wellness
i take it into full context of their
medical history so i look at labs i look
at their medical history i do a full
physical exam to make sure that
cbd and cannabis is something that they
can integrate into their health and
wellness now the
problem is you can't always find a
physician that is knowledgeable about
cannabinoid medicine actually it's very
very rare
so what's wonderful with dr macias and
her dispensaries
is that regulated medical dispensaries
tap into a knowledge base
of physicians plant scientists
cultivators and researchers